こんにちははじめ社長です
皆さんはじめ雪をは好きなお菓子は何か
知っていますでしょうかそう動画の
タイトルにもありますコアラのマーチが
とっても好きなんですよもう私はず3冊を
コアラのマーチがすきすきすきす言い続け
て約100年ついにはじめ車場とコアの町
コラボしましたーー
始め冊ほどコアラの末の子らを結構前から
決まっておりましてずーっといろいろねっ
てようやく今発表できましたありがとう
ございます今回ですねアルミン使用の期間
限定のタックがあるんですよ火筒部に入っ
ていたですのパーティーとかでみんなで
食べてるよねその塩じゃあハロウィン
シェアパックのイラスト
始め雪を考えさせていただきました本来の
園児ハロウィンシュリンプがいろんなお
菓子のパッケージにマーチ食ったコーラの
まずはまあ自分がいたずらしにいろんな
場所に行きましたよっていう感じらしくて
私知恵を絞りに絞ってさまざまな新種の
コアラ作らせていただきました本当に見る
とこちらですどうぞ
ん
きまーす
子は男児ハードですよねハロウィンの
コアラのマーチん
ならを一緒に考えて
説教訴訟や作成僕で大丈夫安全もちろん
話題性ああああソフタップ目を聞く予定だ
ん
ねっと持ったプロサーファー
ています
色逆転これ
胡兵等ございます
くって
あげる
考えるコーラー考えかになるん
ネクザはいどうでしょうか結構ナーン
ギリギリ攻めましたジャブからみたいね
その結構言ってみたりしてはんなり奇抜な
コアラが作られたのかなと思っております
とに早速今手元にエンジョイハロウィーン
シリーズあるんでちょっと見ていき
ましょうかまずはこちらなあコアラの
マーチでめっちゃ濃いんですよ
日てここ豊富0この虚無のでも弾みシャツ
をコアラっていうのがいいんですよ
ありがとうロったらのサーチのパッケージ
取ってる日が来る弾って
なあもう本当に超嬉しいですよ子供の頃
からずっと食べてたお菓子のパッケージの
自分が乗るとは
コアラですけどコアなんですけどどう見て
も俺っていうのはめちゃくちゃうれしい
ですねこれ見て下さいはじめ車2が書いた
コーラが出てくるかもということでこの
小包の中にひょっとしたら僕が書いた
コアラがいるかも知れませんと
めちゃくちゃ丁寧に僕の説明まで書いて
ありますみなさんぜひ
コードを選んでくださいじゃあさっそく
探してみますね
[音楽]
青じゃ普通のパッケージをめっちゃ
かわいいですよ今回も鼻と口はたして僕は
出てくるのでしょうか
欲しい
ああ
うわぁ
ガー
はいうわああああってもレアカー
[音楽]
キター
これですわー皆さん出てきたんですけど
ポイントなのは出てくるかもなんで出てこ
ないかもしれないんですよでゲルが出てこ
ないかはあなた次第頭が僕は部刷りでまし
たけど骨がコアラの末からはドクター
コアラができますあああっっっ
だからこれ攻めてるでしょ一番大事な
コアラんの顔を映さないで10件でアワー
好きすぎて顔が隠れちゃっていっなんか
いける登ったようにせっかくで太郎に
いただきます
今の加工等のまず次がこちらですねえっ
カーナー&クランキーこれでもしっかり僕
にいます全部当てたいんですけど探します
ね
[音楽]
ブービーいますよね自分でやってみ
ましょう今こちらですが puebco
あらでーっ
このなてぃの部分いいして僕といえば
スライムなんでランちゃんヌーラを
スライドしてもらいますさあけっの
パッケージされますてい
スライムわぁなかなかすごいと思っている
コーラじゃないもん2つではボケも大事
ですチョコ by ちょこ場合にも私が
おりますさあ果たしてチョコ場合には
どんな
はじめ冊が増えたコーラが入ってるん
でしょうか俺雪像結構ヤバイかった気が
すん者出て来い
はぁっ
えっ2個入ってた2個入ってたんだけどみ
ました今まずでこっから猫出てきました
からねこちらです逆転コアラ子笑って肌が
黒いじゃないですかこの花の色を逆転させ
て体全身が黒くなっちゃったコアラので
パッと出てきたら毛抜きと思われるんです
けども違うすか手抜きじゃ逆転している
だけなんですねちょっともったいないから
まず普通のパッケージをで食べれば
うんは続いてはこちら
カスタード機器かわいいねえさあこちらに
入っております
何だろう上げます
今んとこ全部出てるデーター
右こ1丁本当にちゃんとした商品から出し
てるんですけどまた2個出ましたはこれは
ちゃったねやりすぎたかなぁ物等です肇
社長が書いたコアラだよって書いてあり
ます透明こうだ
透明なのでいないで初利社長のかいた
コアラでは書いてないんですマリオコアラ
の店全店で書いただけなのでほぼ印刷ミス
よみたいな感じになってますこれは攻め
すぎましたさすがにでもやっぱり
ハロウィンということで透明人間とかも
いるじゃないですかそれからなんかあぁ
当面なコアラとか言いますって聞いたら
ロッテさん今までいませんでしたって
おっしゃってたのであじゃあ等上野耕路で
お願いしますと言ったら
いいですよということで行かせていただき
ますありがとうございますや透明コアラ
生み出したの結構歴史作ったと思ってんだ
よねありがとうございますいただきます
[音楽]
知っ社債がこっちだパイの実でございます
体並みに関してはですね開けてもらったら
分かると思うんですけど小包が答弁になっ
ているんですよねで小包に僕がが入った
コアラいるんじゃなくて袋の裏の方のこの
コアなルームっていますがあるんですけど
ここにはじめした長が書いたコアラがいる
よって言う奴になっておりますこれがいた
んですけど今ですねメガネかけて片手に
スライムが乗っています find に
もう一パターンてこちらに思いますこっち
はもどってですライブ持って入店する
コアラ
愛は済みますねいますすいませます青いい
パーティでどんどんちゃんするの釣りだけ
スライム握ってニコニコしてんの底でパイ
形だけ蒲生田に僕の書いたコアラがい
るっていう感じになっております
ん
王子愛というわけでご覧ください私が考え
たコアラたちですかわいいやつから行かれ
たやつまでたくさんいますがなかなか
ちょっとせ命令たかなと思います個人的に
は透明校あるとかほんと革命を起こしたか
なと個人的に思っておりますさぁ続いてな
んですけれども僕普段普通にあのお菓子と
関わる待ちとかサクサクって食べるだけな
んですけどもロッテさんからあレンジが
紹介したお菓子をアレンジして食べる
なんかさ素敵なレシピを教わったのですね
ちょっと実際に行ってみたいと思います
立つ空気う
アレンジする前に入っての総督をしっかり
していきましょう
そして今回のアレンジレシピはいたずら
まあ地区のハウねとまずカスタードケーキ
を用意しますそしてコアラのマーチを開け
てを今回をカッコイイ松くんができますね
そしてガーナチョコレートを湯煎で溶かし
ましょう溶けたら袋の先を切ってチョコ
ペンにしてさっき出てきたコアラを書いて
みましょう
[音楽]
完成です他にも同じようにチョコ場合でも
作ることができます
[音楽]
もう一つのアレンジルフィがパイの実
ビーフ必要ですまずお皿にご飯を盛ります
そこに鯛の身を率いていきましょう
その上からビーフシチューをかけますもう
美味しそうですね最後に生クリームと
パセリをトントンと影たら完成です
ん
というわけで完成しましたいたずらまあ
地区のハロウィンケーキで州では早速食べ
てみたいと思いますいただきます
ん
取り合う枚定期にチョコが混ぜてるんで
めちゃくちゃおいしいで日続いてはこちら
パイの実ビーフシチューです
米だな米などは避けて食べさせていただき
ます愛飲のミートビーフシチューが合うか
どうかですよねどうなんだろうこんな食べ
方したことないからなっちゃうじゃがいも
と食べますいただきます
[音楽]
うわぁ間に甘いかなと思ったらサクサクの
衣がしなしなになっててビーフシチューと
すごい相性が良いです
うーんまんすいません僕はちょっと今年で
ご飯が食べれないのですでに自分で作って
ご飯と一緒に試してみてくださいはい
そしてですね最高にワクワクする夏をお
届けすべくロッテさんがなんとロッテビス
2020日サマーというものを実施して
おります今回は肇社長とのカロリー
コラボレーションなんですけども他にも
ワークアクスルステージを実施している
みたいです
[音楽]
ブーバー本当にもう
カーヌーン
[音楽]
椅子えっ